bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction en ce
25 novembre voici les principaux titres
que nous allons développer ce soir elle
148 femmes sont mortes en 2012 sous les
coups de leur conjoint c'est un chiffre
qui concerne la france et n'oublions pas
les 46 400 mille femmes déclarés
victimes de violences conjugales ces
deux dernières années et c'est
aujourd'hui la journée internationale
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et aux numéros de téléphone à composer
39,19 c'est aujourd'hui également que
les restos ouvrent leur 29e campagne
d'hiver je recevrai l'un des
responsables de la structure dans les
yvelines dans quelques minutes une
hausse de 5 à 10 % des bénéficiaires est
attendu et puis et culture le salon du
livre d'histoire à versailles qui a
rencontré le succès ce week-end avec la
présence d'auteurs renommés lorànt
deutsch heures robert vélo ou encore
à l'image du jour à jouy en josas devant
les dans les locaux de l'école la
tecomah le trophée jean de la veine qui
vient de se terminer trophée de cuisine
qui rend hommage depuis 2000 à ce chef
étoilé qui s'étaient installés dans le
département notamment à bougival
président du jury pour cette année
thierry marx lui aussi étoilé au guide
michelin adepte de la cuisine
moléculaire juré de l'émission télévisée
top chef nous l'avons rencontré à
l'issue de cette dégustation alors que
les six candidats venus de toute la
france et même pour l'un d'entre eux de
londres venait de terminer leur 5h30 des
preuves
le niveau du concours de genre de l'aven
et toujours un concours de haut niveau
c'est à dire que c'est on a affaire à
des candidats déjà aguerris et il ya une
entrée un plat un dessert à faire cinq
heures trente de travail donc c'est
assez intense
vous avez vu le jury je crois que vous
avez 80% de meilleur ouvrier de france
qui ajoute aux candidats stress
supplémentaire quand vous pouvez
afficher
d'avoir gagné le concours jean de l'aven
et il est évident que ça vous ouvre
quelques portes et une façon de pouvoir
montrer votre savoir faire cesser salle
de la base autre métier savoir faire
savoir faire faire et faire savoir et au
travers de ces concours vous pouvez
montrer votre savoir faire et ça c'est
un petit communication assez important
dans nos métiers pour pouvoir rétablir
sa réputation
le trophée jean de la veine qui sera
remis dans la soirée de ce lundi par à
les toques françaises le vase de sèvres
qui distingue également ses meilleurs
cuisiniers sera décerné par la
présidence de la république les lauréats
à découvrir dans notre édition de demain
mardi le 25 novembre journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'égard des femmes une date
choisie par le procureur de la
république de versailles pour présenter
un dispositif de téléphones portables
d'alert destiné aux femmes les plus en
danger catherine je l'attends un
téléphone portable comme les autres pas
tout à fait celui ci dispose d'une
touche d' alerte en l'activant la femme
victime de violence conjugale est mise
en relation directement avec des
conseillers formés à traiter les
situations d'urgence dans les dix
derniers mois de l'année dans le
département 1800 cas de violences
intrafamiliales ont été relevés six
femmes ont succombé en 2012 sous le coup
de leur conjoint c'est un phénomène qui
atteint la dignité humaine en fait aux
droits des gens et donc une bonne partie
nous échappe encore et j'espère de tout
coeur qu'avec ce dispositif non
seulement nous mettrons en sécurité des
femmes à auquel nous devons protection
mais aussi que nous pourrons faire
révélé d'autres faits par des victimes
qui seront mis en confiance auquel nous
aurons témoigner notre intérêt
indirectement toute personne qui serait
confronté à une femme victime de
violence et qui se dit cette femme pour
effet devrait bénéficier du téléphone
grand danger pour anne ou l'orienter et
nous on sera chargée en fait en tant
qu'association référente de faire un
rapport d'évaluation qu'on enverra au
parquet et le parquet ce sera seul
décideur en fait de l'attribution du
téléphone on n'a pas le pouvoir
d'attribuer le téléphone soit
département par exemple 93 je sais que
c'est dans les dix à douze minutes la
police est là donc ça un dispositif qui
est efficace donc c'est ça l'apport en
fait de ce téléphone actuellement le
procureur de la république dispose de
cinq téléphones portables à terme 15
seront opérationnels
un dispositif déjà testé en seine saint
denis à paris dans le val d'oise dans
13% des cas l'appel depuis ce téléphone
entraîne une réponse policière
la femme en très grand danger va se
sentir ponctuellement en danger va avoir
peur va nous appeler ça c'est 66 % de
nos appels environs où là on va
l'accompagner on va rester dix minutes
en ligne avec elle et je trouve que
c'est le côté très intéressant du
dispositif de rassurer la personne
certes nous avons des cas qui sont des
cas où il ya une confirmation de la
présence de la personne violente et là
nous déclenchons très vite la police
mais nous permettons aussi à la personne
d'avoir de retrouver une vie normale
demain l'opérateur orange partenaire de
l'opération pourrait même rendre le
téléphone géolocalisable
seulement 20% des victimes d'agressions
au sein de leur foyer se déplace à la
police ou en gendarmerie par peur de
représailles et par peur sans doute de
ne pas être assez soutenu pensez vous
que la loi soit assez sévère vous
réagissez à l'actualité chaque soir dans
le journal de la rédaction voici vos
réponses avec ce micro trottoir moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'elle soit très
sévère voilà ce que je pense parce que
les femmes battues qui meurent etc on
n'en parle pas assez
les femmes qui se font battre elles sont
même pas conscients de ce qui leur
arrive et pour elle c'est toujours de
leur faute leur nom c'est pas d'accord
il faut être plus sévère et puis
vraiment les hommes il y en a vraiment
des méchants l'alcool surtout non je
pense pour il faut que ce soit
plus dur un accompagnement parce que
visiblement il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
re qui ont peur de
témoigner ou de porter plainte parce
qu'elle aime toujours leur mari je pense
que les gouvernants devraient être
beaucoup plus vigilant sur ça l'est
peut-être suffisante mais est-ce qu'elle
est appliquée complètement ce sont
beaucoup de casse et c'est ce qui se
passe il ya des lois et puis
si on les applique pas
et de son côté la ministre des droits
des femmes najat vallaud belkacem a
annoncé le doublement des moyens
consacrés à la lutte contre les
violences conjugales 66 millions d'euros
avec notamment la création de 1650 les
nouvelles places d'hébergement d'urgence
à travers la france d'augmentation des
effectifs aussi des travailleurs sociaux
dans les commissariats et les
gendarmeries ainsi que des mesures pour
favoriser les dépôts de plainte autre
sujet 1986 première campagne des restos
du coeur sur une idée lancée au micro
d'europe 1 par coluche je suis million
et demi de repas distribués en france
par quelques 5000 bénévoles 2013 28e
campagne d'hiver qui s'achèvent ce sont
130 millions de repas que 66 mille
bénévoles se sont chargés de distribuer
alors que les restos des buts depuis
aujourd'hui leur 29e saison je reçois
henry fall bonsoir responsable de la
communication dans les yvelines donc
pour les restos du coeur ce matin on
pouvait lire dans la presse que le
nombre de bénéficiaires dans le
département pourrait augmenter de 5 à
10% vous sentez une attente forte sur
cette ouverture de resto sur cette
nouvelle saison on sent on sent qu'une
augmentation
elle sachant que aujourd'hui les
chiffres sont pas calé donc on sait pas
pensé encore il se fait très bien il se
peut très bien que ce soit simplement
des gens qui viennent plus tôt mais
aujourd'hui on a bien une augmentation
de l'ordre de 5 à 10 % des bénéficiaires
qui viennent nous rendre visite on sait
que le département des yvelines est
plutôt hétérogènes en termes de
population vous avez des demandes sur
chacune des zones il ya des endroits où
c'est plus les deux les deux grandes
zones de dison de pauvreté dans les
yvelines c'est la vallée de la seine et
puis toute la nationale 12 donc c'est
râpé long cours qui va jusqu à
rambouillet plus d encore un centre de
cheyrou dans qui sont les centres qui
ont enregistré les instants en tout on a
24 centres plus de restos bébés ce qui
fait 26 centres qui sont répartis et
essentiellement sur ces deux grandes
zones de progrès c'est une question
qu'on vous pose chaque année mais quel
est le profil des bénéficiaires est ce
que ça a évolué d'une année sur l'autre
est ce que ça confirme aussi des
tendances personnes âgées femmes seules
c'est toujours pareil il ya autour des
femmes seules des personnes âgées
mais maintenant des jeunes aussi parce
que c'est de plus en plus difficile de
faire des études de payer ses études et
on a deux de tous les âges de toutes les
catégories des gens qui sont dans le
besoin et le ce qui est intéressant je
pense est de voir que la crise est là et
la crise dure et effectivement
vous avez aujourd'hui plus de
55 % des gens qui redouble c'est dire
qu'ils étaient là l'année dernière et
qui reviennent alors qu'avant on était
plutôt dans les zones de moins de 50 %
il ya même venait c'est un pauvre seul
en fait 25% qui viennent depuis plus de
trois ans alors qu'avant il ya des
restos du coeur normalement c'est pour
s'en sortir et puis après on vient plus
au resto quand on est sortis de l'oeuf
de la bise et aujourd'hui les gens qui
viennent d'arriver ou la santé c'est à
dire que l'on voit que la crise est là
et la crise dure c'est un point qu'on
avait peu dont on n'avait pas conscience
jusqu'à présent on va évoquer cette
distribution d'aidé alimentaire dans le
département des yvelines est pas
uniquement puisque les restos
interviennent aussi pour l'hébergement
d'urgence ou encore l'insertion
professionnelle on en parle juste après
ce reportage d'olivier maniscalco
yolaine thorez elodie moines sur cette
première journée d'action
a priori les articles qu'ils parviennent
à l'ats thomas est faible
ce lundi démarrage de la 29e campagne
d'hiver des restos du coeur à elancourt
une trentaine de bénévoles étaient
présents pour accueillir sur place
hommes femmes et enfants bénéficiaires
des bénévoles a provisionné vendredi par
l'entrepôt des clayes-sous-bois où près
d'un million de repas sont stockés
chaque année et qui permettent
d'alimenter les 24 centres des restos
dans les yvelines chaque semaine le
centre d'elancourt peut ainsi recevoir
et servir près de mille repas le nombre
remonte à 2000 en fin d'hiver est de
plus en plus de gens demandent à être
bénéficiaire chaque année les siens
c'est les probabilités mais je pense
qu'on va avoir encore par rapport à
l'année dernière
8 à 10% d'augmentation gérer toutes les
lacets toutes les situations et toutes
les classes et les jeunes beaucoup de
jeunes
ces étudiants il ya deux ou trois ans
les anciens qui sont arrivés en nombre
un peu plus important maintenant c'est
les mets anciens sont toujours là mais
les plus jeunes les familles
- parental aussi la prise en plus outre
l'augmentation chaque année du nombre de
demandeurs les restos devront dès 2015
faire face à un autre problème la baisse
de 50 % des aides publiques européennes
il faudra donc très vite trouver
d'autres sources de financement pour
l'association lancé par coluche en 1985
en attendant plus d'un million de repas
vont encore être livrés cette année dans
les yvelines plus que jamais les restos
comptent sur vous
le responsable de la communication des
restos dans le département des yvelines
nous accompagnent ce soir dans le
département vous avez 24 centres vous le
disiez tout à l'heure de la distribution
plus deux pour les russes
bbb effectivement ça représente combien
de bénévoles pour le département on a
dans le département neuf cent soixante
bénévoles et c'est stable c'est en
évolution vous voulez nous sommes moins
et donc ce qui prouve que on a quand
même une certaine attirance les
bénévoles viennent mais on recherche
quand même toujours des bénévoles
surtout dans des médias peu spécialisés
comme l'informatique parce que s'ils
voulaient distribuer un million trois
cent mille europe a amené mille tonnes
de marchandises sur l'entrepôt l'heureux
distribuer il faut il faut des moyens
faut de la logistique et on a besoin
d'un logisticien on a besoin
d'informaticiens on a besoin de choses
comme ça et tout ça pour aider près de
4600 famille d'un public plus dans le
département c'est on a aidé l'année
dernière 12 1728 famille effectivement
et et cette année je compense en aura
plus quoi mais douze mille sept cents
familles font millions de repas voilà à
travers ses 26 ans qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure avec des évolutions possibles
sur l'ouverture des centres il est
probable qu'un nouveau centre ouvre
aussi ne serait ce que sur saint quentin
en yvelines on voudrait bien ouvrir un
nouveau centre sur saint quentin parce
que nos deux centres qui sont dans la
périphérie dont qui sont rap d'un côté
et bois d'arcy de l'autre sont saturés
sont des plus apte parmi les plus gros
centre de là des yvelines et un nouveau
centre souhaite bienvenue ce qu'on
voudrait c'est enfin ce qui manque c'est
d'abord un local
quelle quelle dimension précisé ces
moments où je vais passer deux messages
à locale entre 100 et 150 m² rez de
chaussée où tu peux recevoir du public
puisqu'on est là quand même pour
recevoir des bénéficiaires il ya cette
aide alimentaire et puis également il y
à cette aide pour l'insertion que vous
apportez au quotidien là aussi c'est en
hausse les demandes donc le lindane
assertion fait que deux fois douze dans
chacun des deux anciennes chantier
d'insertion ont fait deux fois douze
bénéficiaires par an donc 24 parents
essaient d'imiter parce que on prend des
gens les qui sont désocialisées vraiment
et on les accompagne pour les remettre
dans le chemin du travail et ça on peut
pas faire en 12 personnes par chantier
et par six mois c'est tout ce qu'on peut
faire on peut pas faire plus et toutes
ces têtes bien sûr qu'ils aient toujours
d'une année sur l'autre en tout cas ces
dernières années plus ou moins malmené
puisque vous bénéficiez du plan d'aidé
européen on en a déjà parlé sur ce
plateau le pead est avec des
incertitudes d'une année sur l'autre
aujourd'hui vous avez toujours le
sentiment d'avoir un couperet sur des
diminutions dead pour vous permettre de
mener à bien vos missions j'étais avant
c'était un couperet pour la fin totale
de l'aide donc ce couperet il est parti
donc on sait qu'on aura une aide elle
sera moins importante répartis sur plus
de pays et alain au sein de la france
réparti sur plus d'associations donc les
restos du coeur auront moi donc j'ai
faudra s'en allait réussir à relancer à
maintenir ou à l'activité pour compenser
il faut
plus de ce qu'on appelle entre
guillemets de ramasse donc aller dans
les supermarchés le matin à 6h 5h 6h du
matin trouver des produits qui sont
pour qu'on peut
donner à nos bénéficiaires et qui sont
pas en limite etc des collectes
donc vous en voyez beaucoup d'air et des
supermarchés on a une grande collecte
nationale pour lequel on cherche des
bénévoles occasionnels le 8 et le 9 mars
et puis des collectes dont on a besoin
surtout c'est les collègues pour les
bébés on a on a 500 bébés dans les douze
mille sept cents personnes qu'on à qui
on donne de l'aide alimentaire
500 bébés et on sait qu'on manquera deux
couches qu'on manquera de lait 1er âge
dès le mois de février ou mars et il
faut absolument fins que ceux qui
peuvent se mobilisent et se mobilise
pour apporter des couches du des
premiers âges des petits pots et cetera
pour les bébés donc prenne contact
directement avec vous et puis pour les
dons aussi est liée à l'adresse internet
qui s'est affichée restosducoeur.org ou
sinon directement pour tout ce qui est
donc également auprès de vos structures
absolument
rappelé également quels sont les
critères pour pouvoir prétendre au resto
parce qu'on parlait de cette crise qui
s'installe qui dure de pouvoir d'achat
qui diminue aussi ce que vous revoyez
les critères pour être bénéficiaire
d'une année sur l'autre les d'abord
l'accueil l'accueil au resto du coeur
est inconditionnel dire qu'elle toute
personne vous moi n'importe qui on peut
frapper aux restos du coeur et on est là
pour essayer de traiter le problème
si un problème alimentaire là il ya une
aide qui n'est plus inconditionnels et
conditionnel leaf avec un certain seuil
de ressources qu'on garde pour nous et
qui a un peu augmenté d'une année sur
l'autre vous ajuster en fonction des
interventions des personnels des profils
aussi les personnes qui sont voir
tu compte tenu des difficultés qu'on a
aussi à s'approvisionner on peut pas
remonter et trolls et les niveaux
auxquels devra maintenir la
d'effectivement merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau la campagne des restos pour cet
hiver 29e qui débute en ce 25 novembre
aval se poursuivre jusqu'en mars et les
restos vous continuez ensuite leur
activité ne serait ce qu'à trappe ou
l'antenne est ouvert tout au long de la
nuit absolument on a la plupart de la
plupart des descentes de distribution
sont ouverts font les deux compagnes et
trappes est ouvert toute l'année même en
juillet août voilà les bénévoles qui
sont donc présent mobilisé je vous
rappelle aussi le concert des
c'est important pour récolter des dons
mercredi 15 au lundi 20 janvier c'est à
strasbourg au zénith école occupée
vendredi soir des parents d'élèves se
sont réunis dans l'enceinte de l'école
jean baptiste clément à trappes à
l'appel du syndicat une app ils
protestaient contre la réforme des
nouveaux rythmes scolaires à la sortie
des classes il était prenons peu
nombreux mais au total une quarantaine
de parents se seraient relayés selon
l'association pendant huit heures le
président du mouvement où les coûte à
présent au micro de claire cambier
et surtout de toujours de continuer à
demander la fin de la suspension de
cette grève de cette réforme de se
mettre autour d'une table et de
réfléchir helmand ensemble pour la
rentrée 2014 a un vrai projet qui
respecte le rythme des enfants tels que
tel qu'il est par définition julien est
également le rythme des parents ce qu'on
l'a oublié bon cette réforme est
effectivement avoir des horaires qu'ils
soient réguliers sur la semaine qu'ils
soient
pas trop pas trop chargé et que les
activités et que les activités proposées
soit proposé à tous les élèves et non
pas à une poignée d'élèves à 9 9 %
d'élèves de la ville de trappes la
mairie de trappes qui évoque une
mobilisation de moins d'une demi
douzaine de personnes un mouvement peu
représentatif selon elle aucune
concertation ne devrait donc se tenir
prochainement la station la d'épuration
au carré de réunion fait peau neuve
rénovation agrandissement un projet
écologique qui devrait à couvrir d'ici
2016 les besoins de la plaine de
versailles le reportage de clark embiez
jonathan vilma
sur ce chantier les ouvriers s'activent
il leur reste deux ans pour finir les
travaux de rénovation et
d'agrandissement de la station
d'épuration carré de réunion une mise
aux normes européennes et une
amélioration des performances à terme la
station devrait traiter les eaux usées
de tous les habitants de la plaine de
versailles soit près de 350 mille
personnes côté innovation le
constructeur prévoit de filtrer l'eau
grâce à l'installation de 135 mille
mètres carrés de membranes un procédé
biologique qui ouvre la voie à la
réutilisation des eaux usées on va
beaucoup plus loin dans le traitement de
l'eau on ira ou n'ira on pourra aller
comme ils l'ont fait d'ailleurs dans le
monde par exemple singapour ou à
singapour
l'autre ville que l'on boit ses lourdes
la station d'épuration qui sont traités
donc on y arrivera il faudra peu de
choses l'eau est pour le moment rejetée
dans le rues de gally ce cours d'eau
sera déviée de quelques mètres pour
prévenir les risques d'inondation est
passé sous ce pont autre difficulté du
chantier conserver l'activité de la
station le temps des travaux dernier
point la station est située non loin du
château de versailles le carré de
réunion était d'ailleurs déjà au xviiie
siècle le lieu de rassemblement des eaux
usées du château cette proximité a
obligé les architectes à se fondre dans
le paysage
faute d'avoir les autorisations de
construire toute la toiture on est assez
laid végétalisée maximum pour qu'il ya
un continuum quand on vient de
l'extérieur depuis la plaine agricole la
plaine depuis versailles y at il un
continuum végétal qui passe du terrain
naturel directement sur les toitures
avec un seul coup d'oeil vous voyez pas
la différence entre les bâtiments et le
terrain
les différents bâtiments sont
partiellement aux fruits jusqu'à 11
mètres sous terre des contraintes
techniques qui ont occasionné un surcoût
de 30 à 40% investissement final à 180
millions d'euros la nouvelle station
devrait être en service à la mi 2016
la culture la sixième édition du salon
histoire de lire s'est tenu ce week end
aversa l occasion de côtoyer des auteurs
125 ans autour des auteurs connus et
très connus comme lorànt deutsch par
exemple parfois aussi quelques surprises
pour les visiteurs comme nelson monfort
maxime est venue de créteil pour
rencontrer son idole lorànt deutsch qui
a présenté au salon du livre d'histoire
de versailles son dernier livre hexagone
moi je suis même histoire depuis que je
suis tout petit donc je continue comme
ça
oui et franck ferrand aussi beaucoup de
monde pour saluer cet auteur populaire
venu animer une conférence sur le thème
la france quelle histoire on dit souvent
quand à lire est un succès que c'est du
chiffre mais c'est surtout des visages
et là on voit les visages on voit pas
les chiffres moi ce que j'essaie de leur
faire comprendre c'est que lille s'est
pas justement pour un public averti ou
de la littérature c'est notre réalité
géographique c'est notre réalité nous
avons une histoire et cette histoire là
se déroulent sous nos pieds pour peu
qu'on s'y intéresse un tout petit peu
donc voilà j'essaie de captiver les gens
autour de quelque chose qui est
rassembleur puisque c'est une histoire
qui nous appartient à tous j'apprécie la
façon qu'ils travaillent pour l'histoire
de france en la rendant dynamique
accessible on leur donnera un nouveau
souffle je suis très sensible que je
mange une grande passionnée d'histoire
et ça me fait ça fait vraiment plaisir
de voir le
l'élan autour de l'histoire dans les
allées du salon d'autres visages connus
nelson monfort n'est pas seulement
commentateur sportif il est aussi
l'auteur d'un ouvrage sont les grands
événements sportifs du 20e siècle je
pense c'est un public à la fois averti
et nombreux et moi c'est exactement ce
que j'aime j'aime aller vers les gens
absolument on écrit pour être lu sinon
ça sert à rien il faut sortir des des
cénacles et des lieux confinés en fait
j'ai fait des rencontres extraordinaires
sincèrement et peut-être que des
rencontres qui vont avoir des
répercussions parce que intel m'a dit
qu'il avait des archives extrêmement
intéressante sur un sujet qui pourrait
m'intéresser pour un prochain livre en
tout le salon histoire de lire aura
accueilli pendant ces deux jours 125
hauteur et près de 10000 livres proposés
à la dédicace
10 sport pour conclure cette édition ils
sont joués à rééducateurs ou tout
simplement passionnés de football devant
leur téléviseur forcément au même au
bord du terrain ils ont tous estimé un
jour que l'arbitré n'était pas bon et
cette fois ci il passe de l'autre côté
du terrain pour remplacer justement les
hommes en noir ce reportage d' anthony
rech sur cette formation d'arbitrés
savoir délivrer un carton jaune se
placer lors d'un coup de pied arrêté des
comportements qui peuvent paraître
parfois anodins pour les joueurs mais
qui sont en réalité
indispensable pour un arbitre de
football de son déplacement sur le
terrain peut dépendre le destin d'un
match un arbitre aujourd'hui ne doit
surtout pas d'une influencé le score
doit être là pour protéger les joueurs
ça c'est clair parce que de nos jours la
plupart et au niveau où ils iront
arbitrer en district les joueurs
travaillent le lendemain du match donc
pour ceux qui habitent eux dimanche pas
le lundi les gens travaillent malgré
leur passion pour le ballon rond cette
formation est l'occasion pour certains
de découvrir des règles inscrites dans
les 17 lois du jeu notamment pour le
frappeur d'un tir au but en cours de
match quand la balle touche le poteau il
n'a pas le droit de la récupérer ça doit
être
si elle est remise en jeu c'est
quelqu'un de son équipe qui peut marquer
même lui il peut pas si la balle touche
le goal et que le goal la repousse sur
lui là il peut la rentrée être arbitre
c'est aussi une performance physique au
niveau de la ligue ile de france les
hommes en noir s'entraîne trois fois par
semaine la formation terminée c'est
quand dix d'entre eux le droit de
prendre le sifflet et du plaisir d'une
autre manière en gérant les 22 acteurs
d'une rencontre on appréhende un petit
peu surtout au niveau senior dans les
petites divisions dans les yvelines mais
après les nous on a des bons formateurs
ici qui nous met en confiance et
justement travaillé ce genre de
situation au cas où il pourrait y avoir
des débordements sur un match des
contestations de joueurs donc on nous
met déjà en condition et puis ben voila
je pense que tu as toujours une première
fois à tout donc on verra bien sûr sur
le premier match malgré les critiques
dont fait l'objet l'arbitrage
aujourd'hui ils étaient 48 à vouloir
occuper ce poste sur le terrain preuve
que la passion est toujours plus forte
que les polémiques
chacun dit juste après le journal
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez suivre anthony
rech avec le 7-8 sport l'essentiel des
compétitions du week end replay a dès le
lendemain matin sur notre site internet
aujourd'hui nous en parlait au début de
cette édition et c'était la journée
mondiale de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes nouveaux moyens
nouveaux dispositifs ont été annoncés et
toujours un numéro d'urgence à composer
je me suis pris une forte
j'ai glissé dans ma maison je suis tombé
à vélo ces femmes ont peur de se confier
face aux violences
libérons la parole
entourage collègues de travail
professionnel
nous pouvons tous vous aider
je vous retrouve demain en direct à 18h
pour une nouvelle édition du journal et
dès 18h30 pour un nouveau numéro de
municipales 2014 excellente soirée sur
téléphiles
oui